hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 17 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet Emily Kinney from Walking Dead
was back I wonder how many people saw
this episode and say hey Beth is back
and how many people have never seen
Walking Dead and only know her as
bug-eyed bandit so here's the drinking
game if you want to re-watch this drink
every time someone makes a pun about
bees and drink every time a character
says beacon of hope if you didn't see
the title of the episode was beacon of
hope it's all about Felicity trying to
use Palmer tech to do something positive
there was this promo after the episode
for the Christopher Reeve Foundation and
that's that's all about helping find
cures for paralysis things of that
nature these kind of see behind the
scenes that there were a couple of
different things going on like you have
this story about Felicity with the chip
in her spine
brie larvan wanting to find a way to
walk again after she got her tumor
removed then promoting the Christopher
Reeve Foundation and then you have the
larger plot with damian darhk-- that was
actually a smaller thing in this episode
let's go ahead and do top 10 WTF and
I'll do Easter eggs as we go along there
were a couple big Easter eggs and there
is some notes that I have on the
schedule because the flash is on break
for the next two weeks but arrow is
gonna be new next week and there's
supposed to be a big WTF death so a lot
of crazy stuff going on
starting with number 10 Oliver has read
the Harry Potter books this was kind of
a game of Thrones type joke like where
the book readers make fun of the people
that only watch the TV show what their
movies I didn't even know there were
movies when did Oliver have time to read
the Harry Potter books number nine WTF
they actually addressed that Felicity is
still CEO of a major company that has to
earn profits this is one of the problems
with a big show with a bunch of
characters is that you can't always
directly address the stuff that's going
on in the background like this whole
time that Felicity's been working with
team arrow this season she's also been
CEO of a fortune 500 company they kind
of addressed this with Oliver during
season two I mean Oliver wasn't a great
business person to begin with all of his
neglect for his business activities
really bit him in the ass he lost his
company so it's actually really normal
now that Felicity's off of team arrow
she'd be spending all this extra time
devoted to helping Palmer tech be a good
company just in the context of this
episode they're trying to turn that mr.
terrific prototype chip in her spine
into an actionable item that they can
sell something
it's affordable Felicity's comments were
just that it's super expensive so like
nobody would be able to buy it like his
commentary on the rising cost of health
care but whatever mister terrific makes
something that's really awesome they're
trying to sell it so that Palmer tech
can get super-rich number eight felicity
wants to use it to help people so just
expect to see a version of Smoak
technologies start to rise up through
the course of this season and next
season too this is all really good stuff
for Felicity's character especially like
her going up against brie larvan if you
want Felicity to be a fully fledged
character in her own right she has to
have her own villains her own nemesis
that she faces so the more Felicity
centric villains the better
number seven WTF Merlyn tells damian
darhk-- that he's pretty much out of
hive hive says that they're happy to
keep him in prison the reason being that
they're not super comfortable with the
mysticism that he's been using and it
seems like he's lost most of his power
because Merlyn has that performance joke
he's basically telling him his penis
doesn't work which means that the first
chance he gets
damian darhk-- is going to throttle the
[ __ ] out of Merlyn
I'd say kill him but John Barrowman has
already made comments that make it seem
like he's definitely coming back for
season five so whatever revenge he gets
on Merlin it's not going to involve
killing him you may have heard damian
darhk-- mention the name monument point
that's a big city it's gonna come back
and be a thing later this season
monument point is actually a big
location in a Justice Society story
written by Marc Guggenheim so I feel
like there's some Justice Society of
arrow stuff happening in the background
but that remains to be seen how big that
ends up being there's a very big story
so if I think it's going in that
direction I'll explain what that story
is it was basically the last big Justice
Society story before flashpoint so it
was actually a couple years ago
number six mr. terrific accidentally
makes his way into the arrow cave you
get super fanboy moment this is great
you're kind of like a male Felicity he
kind of lands himself on Diggle [ __ ]
list because he knows who all the other
members of team arrow are but then he
points to Diggle knows like I don't I
don't know who you are you don't look
familiar so whatever they're cool it
just seems like for now they're gonna
keep Felicity at Palmer tech in mister
terrific will be the fill-in I know he
has the conversation with his boyfriend
at the end of the episode where he's
like that adventure told me that I need
to be here this is where I belong
there's no way that's gonna stick he's
mister terrific he's a comic book
character of course they're gonna find a
reason for him to have to go back and
work with team arrow but number five WTF
probably the most controversial mister
terrific moment in the episode Oliver
kind of makes him cry a little bit even
though mr. terrific is not a huge comic
book character in the in the grand
scheme of things when you look at some
of the other characters that arrow does
all understand that people are really
upset with writing the character this
way being overly sensitive when he's
actually kind of a badass like you see
him flipping around whenever the bees
start attacking he's a bronze medal
decathlete which means proven badass but
yeah Oliver making him cry seems a
little bit weird number four no beats
you have brie larvan be combiner robot
the moment I saw this all I could think
about was Devastator from transformers
and normally I would think that this is
kind of cheesy with all the bee puns in
this episode but really like the whole
the whole episode was told more from
Felicity's perspective and she's kind of
a ridiculous character to begin with
like that's kind of where her energy
flows from just bring realize silly and
inappropriate so I felt like some of the
creative choices in this episode were
appropriate given that the episode was
more in Felicity's tone if this would
have been an episode about Oliver versus
damian darhk-- yeah would have been a
little more inappropriate when the story
focuses on Felicity I feel like he could
have a little bit more fun so give me
all your Nicolas Cage jokes
I was waiting so long to use this Jeff
and arrow has rewarded me accordingly
it was wonderful there was also a my
girl reference and if you don't know
what that movie is it's a Macaulay
Culkin film with a very big be twist at
the end I don't want to give away the
spoiler for that number three WTF though
Felicity's mom is out of control now if
you wonder why they let her mom be so
ridiculous in episodes like this like
they really write her over the top the
reason they use her in stories is really
to make the Felicity character seem more
grounded normally Felicity's the
ridiculous character so when you want
her to seem more serious you just bring
her mom in because her mom is so over
the top that Felicity kind of retreats
into herself like oh Jesus why you got
to be here mom why you got to be so
crazy and wear such low cut tops
Felicity's mom apropos of nothing I feel
like she works really well in the right
doses the number two WTF Felicity
despite the thrill of defeating brie
larvan is not read
joining team arrow I think that she will
eventually I think it's pretty clear
that there's gonna be some big death on
the team and it'll catalyze the rest of
the group it'll bring them back together
but the real question is is how many
more episodes it's gonna be before
Felicity's back on the team probably
before the end of the season now there
was a promo for next week's episode
11:59 that's the name of the episode it
makes it sound like whoever's gonna die
whoever you know whichever member of
team arrow will die at 11:59 that makes
me think that this limo scene is
actually maybe like an episode or two
after that someone dies they have the
funeral then slowly Felicity comes back
onto the team but the problem is is that
we're gonna get that episode next week
then arrow goes on break for at least a
week or two like the flash is on break
right now so the schedule is really
whacked out so I'll be I'll be doing
bonus videos next week where I'll talk
more about that but really my number one
WTF is that Andy Diggle diggle's brother
is working with Merlyn so I know it
seems like based on the promo and based
on this end tag with diggle's brother
Diggle sounds like the person that might
end up dying just be careful not to take
that bait just to make more bee puns
usually promos are cut to be
intentionally misleading let me know in
the comments what did you think about
this like Felicity centric episode and
based on the promo for next week's
episode in this the stuff that happened
at the end of this week's episode who do
you think is going to die the way
they've been trying to hype it is that
it's gonna be someone who's been around
for many seasons if not the beginning of
the show and they even have the tagline
and that promo where it said the end of
an era which just sounds so epic but the
promo seemed kind of anticlimactic so
it's like how big is the character is
this a person that's oh gee team arrow
is this going to be one of the comic
book characters the title of the episode
after 11:59 I'll say this they haven't
released it officially but it's supposed
to be canary cry which makes me feel
like the dead person is part of the
Lance family there's a compelling case
to be made for a couple different
characters that could die but just
remember to the tag line end of an era
so it's definitely going to be a major
thing so in related news I know there's
been a whole bunch of Jonah Hex stuff
happening with legends of tomorrow I'll
try to do a video for that I think
there's new legends of tomorrow this
week I think there's a new episode so
they'll either be an episode
for that or if there isn't an episode
I'll just do a trailer video but the
WonderCon presentation that they did for
that was actually pretty exciting so if
you're behind on legends of tomorrow now
is the time to catch up while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for the Suicide Squad trailer
I just did and you can click here to
learn all about that deleted scene from
Batman V Superman very much Justice
League setup thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight